think of that powerful memory
[Music]
[Applause]
make it
the happiest you can remember
it feels like no time has passed
and loads of times past now i've lived
half my life on the set of harry potter
and spent so much time with the cast and
crew that it will be a rare peak behind
the curtain into a world we have yet to
reveal to anyone outside our harry
potter family
sorry it feels kind of emotional
actually
she's so much like myself
i mean i was
seriously seriously nerdy and i was very
kind of insecure like she was i was
quite a tomboy i wasn't super popular or
anything so i basically was her to be
fair sort of physically we've all sort
of uh changed a lot that doesn't really
describe me at all really
especially the tall part
i'm ginger that's the main thing
i would certainly be going yeah draco
malfoy
he starts off as the ultimate sort of
slimy head get if you will and he slowly
very slowly matures to the sixth film
where he realizes that he you know he
wants more than just a sort of
two-dimensional uh
relationship with harry he wants to get
involved so to speak
enjoy the ride back to london
they're all voldemort fans i wasn't
expecting that you realize what they're
asking you to do is extraordinary and i
saw
and then i took it a bit more seriously
my sister has children who are then
around 10 11 12 and i said marth i don't
know about this baltimore what you're
being asked to play voldemort
you've got to do it
one of the highlights of my part was
when i had to pretend to be hermione
pretending to be better trick i don't
like to be kept waiting i've still got
their teeth actually i'll put them in if
you want
our mantra for the crew was let's make
something timeless let's make something
that when people are watching this 15 20
years from now it feels as if it might
have been made yesterday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's been lovely to see everyone it
really has i didn't know if it would be
i thought because i have a very mixed
relationship with nostalgia because it's
it's just so much feeling that it can be
weirdly painful sometimes because
there's so much of life to take in that
happened to those 10 years something
happened where it was just like the
comfort of the people that i've known
for such a long time
and the history that we share and that
sense of safety
and then i think once i started feeling
really safe just like enjoying
everything that we made and that we
created and and feeling like we could
kind of celebrate and just enjoy being
together this is the perfect time to to
sit down with everyone and and kind of
reminisce because it's i mean it's so
nostalgic and it's everywhere
it's never really left me it's kind of
you know it's found so many different
new lives and uh
even the music can kind of stir it for
me so there's so much nostalgia i think
threaded into these movies and
hello everyone you are about to see the
special features for the harry potter
films october 2nd 2000 the day it all
began there was magic and chaos we're
talking shocking allergic reactions a
mortified young actor and paparazzi
worries
we've got exclusive raw footage from the
very first day magic was made and we can
confirm mischief was definitely managed
he shows up to set he cries on cue and
nails his first day in front of everyone
as the harry potter
you're a wizard harry
okay well it wasn't so simple as that
this touching final scene of the film
was the first to be shot and radcliffe
pulled out all the stops but not on
purpose ever notice that his eyes appear
blue in only this scene the crying
wasn't because of his skills radcliffe
was just having a really rough allergic
reaction to the contacts to change his
eye color at least it worked for the
shot we're not allowed to do magic away
from hogwarts you know that
he was a young actor in a new major role
making odd choices was a given but the
shades on set well this one was new but
hey let the actor do what he needs to do
right yeah i'm going to take my last
minute excellent if it works it works
but these glasses weren't a character
choice no one caught on to the fact that
little radcliffe might have had
something to hide and honestly it was
enjoyable for the crew to watch on as
the actor marked out his scenes takes on
a completely different
look with sunglasses the secret behind
the cool dude sunglasses
his eyes were so sensitive because of
the allergic reaction from the contacts
that little radcliffe was too
embarrassed to say anything and just
tried to hide it obviously he was
committed to his job from the very
beginning
[Music]
are you excited
just when we thought we couldn't love
emma watson anymore
her excitement and energy to be on the
scene was adorable and it's clear from
the very start that she really was
hermione
little watson was also clearly ready to
handle all the media interviews and bts
moments to come do we think she knew how
much the camera loves her we feel you
emma we feel you yeah my first day
filming are you excited i'm really
excited i can't wait to summon up the
first day on set bringing this magical
world to the screen well
watson says it best it feels absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
hey kid welcome to work would you mind
sitting on this broom rig and flying
high in the air for everyone to see
cool
okay so the crew probably went over some
safety measures and made sure matthew
lewis was safely rigged up but still
talk about an intense first day the
actor did his famous neville on a
broomstick sequence and really made a
splash riding on that chaotic rig while
it was definitely cool
the young actor was so far out of his
comfort zone and dove right into the
deep end
gotta give him credit though he nailed
this terrified performance although
really he was probably just going method
and fully terrified no idea what to
expect you know i've never done anything
like that in my life
rupert grint so pretty with barrettes in
his hair
but don't let him hear it the adorable
actor's cheeks turned as red as his hair
when caught by the cameras preparing for
his very first day
if only he knew about the frilly dress
robes that were to come in a few years
his dainty barrettes made the actor
awfully nervous before he got to film
but once the hair and makeup team
finished and he felt like ron weasley
there was no stopping this firecracker
you go glen cocoa
filming massive scenes filled with magic
and a huge number of young actors many
of which have never experienced being on
a set before
well it's a pure recipe for disaster but
the hp squad made literal magic happen
after a couple of key lessons that is it
was one task to get the actors to
actually focus long enough to be able to
get a solid take but the real issue was
the fact that half of them didn't even
know what action meant chris columbus
and david yates had probably never run
into this issue before but eventually
they capture the shots this was one of
the many lessons learned and hurdles
that came with working with all these
young witches and wizards
while some actors weren't ready to go on
action
radcliffe had the opposite problem on
his first big day of filming the
excitement of a new set is definitely
overwhelming but the harry potter actor
was jumping on his queues a bit too
quickly while it is important to go on
action it's equally important not to go
before action is called it took a while
but hey for this iconic wave
totally worth it all right dan you'll be
waving as the train leaves this time
lean out just a little more
he may have been young but radcliffe was
no stranger to the realities of being an
actor after doing david copperfield and
he was on high alert what for
the paparazzi of course it was only his
first day but maybe somehow he knew just
how big a sensation he was going to
become
what he did
can't get anything past you dan the
young actor knew both how to handle and
charm the press and everyone behind the
scenes of course
okay get back to work
people need to pamper you
[Music]
while he'd been preparing to play the
role for a while and had already been on
set working for a couple days for
initial photography nothing could
prepare him for what it would be like
when the pressure was really on and the
movie was going full steam ahead on the
hogwarts express quite literally
fair play dan we would be too but
luckily he had a whole lot of support
behind him and a team ready to make
magic clearly the boy who lived does
well under pressure
[Music]
these number
one
from the outset the harry potter team
was determined to stay as true to the
books as they could but obviously some
changes had to be made what with
radcliffe's eyes watering with contacts
in and emma watson's inability to speak
clearly these are teeth number three and
i think these are the best they may have
been the best teeth but they really
weren't up to par
yeah all these fake teeth tried on
during her teeth test may have looked
pretty good but they made it real tough
for watson to sound as eloquent as she
does as hermione it's leviosa not
leviosa
and really what would we do without that
epic line a mumbling actress definitely
wasn't sustainable for eight films so
the teeth got the boot the best teeth of
all were much closer to home
[Music]
instead of going over lines or getting
worried about what he needed to film
radcliffe let his age show hanging out
and making small talk about the olympics
with the crew
well he's guaranteed a silver yep
calm cool and collected all while
charming and getting to know the people
that would become like his family and
watch him grow up i didn't really expect
to
to get emotional even though it was kind
of 10 years of my life
she only had one scene but that didn't
stop the actress from totally reveling
in all the magic at just nine years old
little bonnie didn't understand what a
set was but she knew how to stand and be
adorable for the cameras and hey it
worked we wouldn't know it but the
littlest weasley was totally overwhelmed
and nervous and not just because she was
in the company of her future wizard
husband we're totally jealous of the
fact that in her very first job on set
she got to hang out with the dame julie
walters acting royalty much being on set
is a lot less intimidating with an
acting legend there to take you under
their wing especially one this feisty do
you want a bit of malarkey
a room full of smiling young actors
is there anything better for chris
columbus it probably would have been
this same room full of young actors but
actually focused instead of just
grinning ear to ear in awe what did he
expect though really
the group scenes were as hectic as you'd
imagine all while being perfectly
adorable as for the golden trio well
they weren't getting stellar grades just
yet since they hardly could get through
a scene without laughing or just getting
too distracted thank goodness the
editing team was well versed in cuts
since most of the movie had to be put
together line by line and shot by shot i
think everyone's a bit more
kind of relaxed really
imagine having to perform an epic role
as a young kid with hundreds of people
there to witness every moment and that's
a go on stage fright luckily little dan
managed it extremely well when it came
to his performance but behind that
lightning bolt scar and round glasses
the actor was jittering with nerves
solid work considering so many people on
set were curious and waiting to get
close to the young whiz
from day one grint was guilty of
laughing throughout scenes this was a
bad habit that wound up lasting the
entire franchise but in the early days
alan rickman decided to take little
grint under his wing a well-respected
actor by this point rickman had some
tricks up his sleeve
when it came to trying not to laugh
during a scene just try to rest your
face and keep your mind clear
this advice worked for the snape actor
but rupert
well
obviously not so much people's last days
and
i'm just like oh i don't know
i don't know it's just happening
hogwarts will always be there to welcome
us home however there was a time when
the harry potter cast had to say goodbye
to hogwarts for good the deathly hallows
part 2 was dark and intense and you'll
soon find out that behind the scenes
wasn't much different we're uncovering
just how emotional surprising and of
course magical the final days on the set
of harry potter were yeah but i have
i've had a
really nice time
needless to say the last day on set for
daniel radcliffe emma watson and rupert
grint was tense it also didn't help that
their last scene wasn't ideal sad right
the movie may have ended with the
beautiful epilogue on platform nine and
three quarters 19 years in the future
but for the golden trio their harry
potter journey ended surrounded by a
green screen while they continuously
jumped onto a mat it would turn into the
epic scene of their characters running
through the ministry of magic in the
final cut but as producer david barron
put it they took it in turns diving on
the crash mat and after two or three
times that was it that was the end of
harry potter
all in all it was kind of anticlimactic
for a franchise that was the exact
opposite when cut was called for the
final time the three of them broke down
into tears it's not surprising that
daniel called the whole ordeal bizarre i
was so upset on the last day i really
was
after they wrapped the three leads were
brought to a screen where they watched
an extremely emotional video that
production had put together there were
laughs hugs and some more tears but the
real heart-wrenching moment was when dan
gave this emotional goodbye speech i
love this place this has been my life
and so it's gonna be very very odd i
think for all of us if you thought your
life was completely changed when harry
potter came to an end imagine how they
were feeling at that moment we just hope
they had all the fun at their wrap party
that night it just always seemed such a
far away
thing really what's a party without
gifts right emma and dan 100 were not
ready for how bizarre their rap gift
from rupert was going to be as a tribute
to their 10 years as the most iconic
trio rupert gifted emma and dan wait for
it engraved trumpets yes like the
musical instrument he says he has no
idea why he just thought it'd be a good
idea
rupert gave me a trumpet which he had
self-engraved i don't play the trumpet
for daniel wrapping his time on harry
potter meant being extremely unsure of
his future after all at that time he had
spent more than half his life on that
warner brothers movie set like dan said
there'll never be a frame of any of
these films that i don't look at and
connect immediately to a memory he
always mentioned how much he'd actually
miss harry himself harry was like a best
friend to dan and we all know we never
forget a best friend stuff i got to do
in this part which which i
loved and will probably never have a
chance to do again emma's final days on
set had her reflecting on how grateful
she was to have the opportunity to star
in these films in the first place and be
able to play a character who was so
independent outspoken and smart from the
outgoing 11 year old auditioning in her
drama class to a household name she
truly believes they were all lucky
enough to be real-life chosen ones we
were the chosen ones yeah
rupert's goodbye to ron might have been
the hardest only because he said they
basically became one person take a
listen i'm gonna miss can't play wrong
but just like dan rupert struggled with
the fact that he wasn't entirely sure
what life was without ron and harry
potter but he still brought his iconic
ice cream truck to set on the last day
for everyone to enjoy it's kind of been
my life every day every hour so it's
what it's all been about to not have
that anymore it's quite emotional tom
felton wasn't a part of the golden trio
but harry potter was in his life just as
long he was so grateful for everything
he got to learn in those years i've
grown up around some of these incredible
people
i've learned so much as an actor his
last day on sets consisted of filming
multiple endings for draco while this
scene where draco redeemed himself by
fighting with his schoolmates was cut
tom was still proud of the development
he was able to give draco over the years
overall filming on the deathly hallows
part 2 was a great experience for tom he
even got to work alongside his then
girlfriend who starred as draco's future
wife astoria greengrass in the epilogue
i think in that respect we've learned a
lot and we've taken a lot from the place
it's it's only going to be positive
things really another longtime cast
member matthew lewis who played neville
longbottom also had the time of his life
bringing his character's transformation
to life his last day on set was spent
filming scenes of the battle of hogwarts
where neville became an integral part of
defeating the dark lord from an 11 year
old who lost his toad to an adult who
slayed nagini with the sword of
gryffindor he definitely got some of the
best development last ten years that
evolution of a character has been
incredible however we were shocked to
find out that neville's scene with
voldemort was the first time matthew had
ever spoken to rafe fines even though
they'd both starred in the franchise for
years that is alan and david thulis last
day on harry potter if you need proof
that alan rickman was wildly different
from professor snape here it is on his
last day on set he spent hours in his
trailer drinking tea and talking to the
younger cast members about what they
were planning to do with their careers
specifically matthew lewis who had been
scared of him for a decade but had
finally worked up the nerve to speak
with him you know it was because i was
terrified but you were incredible and i
just want to say thank you for allowing
me to work with you for 10 years apart
from giving advice to his younger
co-stars allen's last scenes were filmed
in the hogwarts great hall where he had
to duel with maggie smith also known as
professor mcgonagall he said it was one
of the most awkward scenes he'd ever had
to film because of the respect he had
for maggie but it had to be done
part of his final scene was actually
meant to be cut from the final films
until j.k rowling stepped in and saved
the moment by requesting all the battle
scenes stay true to the novels it was a
very changing thing of course as it
would be over 10 years all in all it was
an emotional few weeks as each cast
member reached their final days on set
of harry potter final bows hugs and
tears seemed to be the main theme behind
the scenes of the deathly hallows part
2. no matter how big or small their
roles were each actor played an integral
role in making the wizarding world as
amazing as it is going through her own
journey but very very much
her own self the truth is after a decade
of spending almost every day together
the cast and crew became one big family
they celebrated birthdays and holidays
together there was never a day on set
that went by where they didn't make
lasting memories with one another i
am still very much in touch with
everyone that i worked with the final
battle was the last scene a lot of the
cast filmed and was even where this
iconic cast photo was taken but just
listen to the cast explain how eerie it
was to be filming on the set of a
destroyed hogwarts with rubble and body
limbs scattered everywhere yeah it's
quite sad seeing it all smashed up
because we've kind of grown up here
the crew even ran into some problems
when they were destroying the hogwarts
set in preparation for the scenes the
set caught on fire and cost the studio
thousands of dollars talk about going
out with a bang while filming the
epilogue the studio went through a lot
to make sure no paparazzi caught sight
of the cast with their aged makeup they
had stand-ins acting as dan emma and
rupert who led the public to an entirely
different place to where they were
filming on location oh my god
that was really funny
while it's been over a decade since the
cast spent their final days on set
they're still showing their love for the
franchise in a lot of ways all the proof
you need is in the cast fangirling over
the wizarding world at universal studios
here or one peek at tom felton's tick
tock at the end of the day the cast is
just like us people who fell in love
with a story about the boy who live yeah
i mean definitely there's there's
emotions it's
those
movies where our childhood we grew up on
those sets so it has incredible meaning
to all of us i think